las tres B simbolizan el Trío
ultraconservador que sigue siendo el
núcleo de la base electoral de Jake
Durante este mandato el ictus salen
Gómez freitas se sintió valorado por el
presidente ultraderechista
recuerde una época en la que ningún
político presentó ningún respeto a la
policía a las familias que perdieron a
sus policías
conozco a Yahir Mesías bolsonaro de esa
época era un simple diputado federal
pero iba a los funerales de nuestros
colegas rendía homenajes decir veía al
policía como un ciudadano
el ex policía se define como Padre de
Familia conservador Pro armas y terror
de la izquierda y votará para allí por
su narró el 30 de octubre
tal como Marisa ruso Pérez es una
profesora jubilada y evangélica teme que
si el izquierdista Lula vuelve al poder
se imponga una educación contraria a sus
creencias
tenemos principios cristianos así que
por ejemplo el aborto es algo anticristo
cristiano
por lo que nos preocupa si un candidato
que piensa así se pone en una posición
de Liderazgo y nos impone esto es muy
difícil
una derrota de Jair bolsonaro iría
también en contra de los intereses de
Carlos moresco productor agropecuario
después de un gobierno que favoreció
como ningún otro a lo largo de negocio
soy una persona Leal a los que son
leales a los valores y principios en los
que creo y nuestro presidente tiene
estos valores morales y sabe valorar
tanto a los pobres como a los ricos
Por eso creo que merece tener otros
cuatro años para poder concluir el
trabajo que se propuso hacer en el país
el agro negocio tiene un el poder
depresión política por sus números sus
diputados y senadores y aporta casi el
28% del pib de Brasil